I was actually like low-key pretty good at it, who I'm not gonna lie. Sarah Burke grew up in Hawaii, just outside of Honolulu. When I was in high school, I visited New York for the first time, and noticed that a lot of vintage shops had all these super tacky Hawaiian shirts,
说实话，我当时其实还挺擅长这个的，我不撒谎。莎拉·伯克（Sarah Burke）在夏威夷长大，就在檀香山郊外。我上高中的时候，第一次去纽约，发现很多古着店里都有那种超级俗气的夏威夷衬衫，
and then it was this cool thing to wear with like skinny jeans. Do you, this is like a thing, right? Yeah, that was totally a thing. And it's still kind of a thing now. These days, high-end designers are making versions of Hawaiian shirts. Hawaiian shirts are in style. And we just thought it was the most hilarious trend.
然后把它们和紧身牛仔裤搭配在一起竟然成了一种很酷的穿法。你懂的，这算是一种潮流，对吧？没错，那确实完全是一种潮流。而且直到现在，它依然算是一种潮流。如今，高端设计师们都在制作各种版本的夏威夷衬衫。夏威夷衬衫正流行。我们当时觉得这简直是最搞笑的趋势。
Like, why it just seemed so ridiculous to us to wear a Hawaiian shirt with Ray Bans. Like, we would never do that. Well, first of all, they wouldn't call them Hawaiian shirts. No one would say Hawaiian shirts. In Hawaii. That just sounds ridiculous. In Hawaii, they're Aloha shirts, and they're slightly different. The Aloha shirt is a very common thing to wear. In Hawaii, everyone has an Aloha shirt, and it doesn't look the same as a Hawaiian shirt.
比如，为什么穿夏威夷衬衫配雷朋眼镜对我们来说看起来那么荒谬。我们绝对不会那样穿。好吧，首先，他们不会管那叫“夏威夷衬衫”。在夏威夷，没人会说“夏威夷衬衫”。那听起来太荒谬了。在夏威夷，它们叫“阿罗哈衬衫”（Aloha shirts），而且它们略有不同。阿罗哈衬衫是一种非常常见的穿着。在夏威夷，每个人都有一件阿罗哈衬衫，它看起来和那种“夏威夷衬衫”不一样。
I don't know about you, but I think of Hawaiian shirts as having like, teaky heads and bikini ladies on them. Aloha shirts are a little more professional. Aloha shirts are like more toned down, you know, like really tasteful floral prints. If you're going out to a nice occasion, you would wear an Aloha shirt. Really? Yeah, it's a very common thing, most men own one, but it's definitely still a product of colonization. You know what I mean? Like, it's not like, back in the day, Native Hawaiians were all walking around in like a low-ha shards, you know what I mean?
我不知道你怎么想，但我心目中的夏威夷衬衫上面印着提基神像（tiki heads）和穿比基尼的女士。阿罗哈衬衫则更显专业。阿罗哈衬衫更低调，你知道的，比如非常有品位的花卉印花。如果你要参加正式场合，你会穿一件阿罗哈衬衫。真的吗？是的，这非常普遍，大多数男人都有一件，但它绝对仍然是殖民主义的产物。你明白我的意思吗？就像，并不是说在过去，夏威夷原住民都穿着阿罗哈衬衫到处走，你懂我意思吗？
Articles of interest. A show about what we wear. And so maybe the idea is about clothing. You can attach ideas about class. An idea of home to a piece of cloth. These are glass, or a macaque, or a macaque. I want it. Any fork and wear clothes.
《感兴趣的物品》（Articles of Interest）。一档关于我们穿什么的节目。所以也许这个概念是关于服装的。你可以将关于阶级的想法、关于家的想法附着在一块布料上。这些是玻璃，或者猕猴，或者猕猴。我想要它。任何叉子和穿衣服的人。
But if you haven't got the attitude and style to carry it off, man, you're just the closed balls. And then we make markers, which are the jigsaw pieces of the shirt. That is the sound of an Aloha shirtmaker wielding a giant industrial blade. And he is cutting through about 50 layers of brightly patterned fabric, stacked in a pile. He's cutting all of the puzzle pieces out. And these cut pieces of fabric will fit together like a perfectly planned jigsaw puzzle. And so the stack of 50 fabric squares will create 50 Aloha shirts.
但如果你没有驾驭它的态度和风格，伙计，你只是个穿着球衣的人。然后我们制作标记，它们就像衬衫的拼图碎片。那是阿罗哈衬衫制造商挥动巨型工业刀片的声音。他正在切割大约50层堆叠在一起的色彩鲜艳的图案面料。他正在切出所有的拼图碎片。这些裁剪好的面料碎片将像精心规划的拼图一样拼合在一起。所以这50层布料堆叠起来将制作出50件阿罗哈衬衫。
Is the back of the shirt? That's the placket? That's the front panels? That's the yoke? There's the collars and the pocket over there. Jason Morgan, the general manager of Kahala Sportswear, has shown me around Kahala's factory and design studio on Oahu. Kahala makes Aloha shirts, and it's actually one of the earliest companies to do so. It's been around since 1936.
这是衬衫的背面吗？那是门襟？那是前片？那是育克？那边是领子和口袋。卡哈拉运动装（Kahala Sportswear）的总经理杰森·摩根（Jason Morgan）带我参观了卡哈拉在欧胡岛的工厂和设计工作室。卡哈拉生产阿罗哈衬衫，它实际上是最早生产这种衬衫的公司之一。它从1936年就开始存在了。
And as Jason and I watch this worker, definitely cut out the puzzle pieces in the stacks of shirts. You can see that all the different parts are strategically placed along the pattern of the fabric. So Jason informs me with pride. So we always match our pocket. And so that is why that pocket is specifically placed right there. When Jason says match the pocket, he means that the breast pocket of the shirt doesn't disrupt the overall pattern. Like the breast pocket will be a continuation of the design so that it blends in at first blush. You don't even notice it.
当杰森和我看着这位工人熟练地切出衬衫堆里的拼图碎片时，你可以看到所有不同的部分都根据面料的图案进行了战略性放置。所以杰森自豪地告诉我：“所以我们总是对齐口袋。”这就是为什么那个口袋被专门放在那个位置。当杰森说“对齐口袋”时，他的意思是衬衫的胸袋不会破坏整体图案。胸袋会是设计的一种延续，这样它在第一眼看上去时就能融为一体。你甚至都不会注意到它。
It looks like it's a lot of extra effort. It's a lot of extra effort. It signifies a higher quality garment, just more attention to detail. There are a few ways to tell if you're looking at a real authentic high-quality aloha shirt. If the pocket matches the pattern, that's a good sign, but it's not the be-all-end-all. Much of the understanding of an aloha shirt is about paying attention to what is on the shirt itself. If it tells a story and it has real references that are specific to Hawaii. If there's a fish in the print, we know what fish that is and that you can find it out
这看起来需要很多额外的努力。确实需要很多额外的努力。它象征着更高质量的服装，只是对细节的关注更多。有几种方法可以判断你看到的是不是一件真正正宗的高品质阿罗哈衬衫。如果口袋与图案对齐，这是一个好迹象，但这并不是唯一的标准。对阿罗哈衬衫的理解很大程度上在于关注衬衫本身的内容。如果它讲述了一个故事，并且有真正针对夏威夷的具体参考。如果印花里有一条鱼，我们知道那是什么鱼，而且你可以在岛屿周围的水域里找到它。
here in the waters around the islands. You know, we're not going to slap something on a shirt just to do it because it looks cool. It's not about a fantasy vacation land. It's about a real place. All the animals, all the fruit, all the landmarks will all be real and significant to Hawaii or to the many cultures that have melted into it. How would you describe this?
你知道，我们不会仅仅因为它看起来很酷就随便把它印在衬衫上。这不是关于一个幻想中的度假胜地。它是关于一个真实的地方。所有的动物、所有的水果、所有的地标都将是真实的，并且对夏威夷或融入其中的多种文化具有重要意义。你会怎么描述这个？
So this is a classic, a pario. And the pario is just a simple, one-colored ground, one-color print. The pario print is a classic pattern of cahalas since the 60s. It's white flowers on a solid color background. This pario pattern features breadfruit flowers, because breadfruit was a primary staple of a lot of Polynesian cultures. Going back to what they call the canoe plants, which were the plants that the Polynesians took with them as they explored Polynesia. And as they explored, Polynesian sailors discovered Hawaii
这是一个经典款，叫“帕里奥”（pario）。帕里奥只是一种简单的、单色底、单色印花的款式。帕里奥印花是卡哈拉自60年代以来的经典图案。它是纯色背景上的白色花朵。这种帕里奥图案以面包果花为特色，因为面包果是许多波利尼西亚文化的主要主食。追溯到他们所说的“独木舟植物”，也就是波利尼西亚人在探索波利尼西亚时随身携带的植物。在探索过程中，波利尼西亚水手发现了夏威夷，
and migrated there in significant numbers. These kinds of specific cultural references, or rather specific multicultural references, are what makes the difference between a loha wear and resort wear. Resort wear is global in its appeal, whereas a loha wear is more informed by what makes Hawaii unique. It's something that, you know,
并大量移民到那里。这些具体的文化参考，或者更确切地说是具体的多元文化参考，正是阿罗哈服饰与度假服饰的区别所在。度假服饰的吸引力是全球性的，而阿罗哈服饰则更多地受到夏威夷独特之处的影响。这是一种，你知道的，
bankers wear in downtown Honolulu. And it's true, bankers are in a Loahah shirts in downtown Honolulu. Everybody is. They even wear them for funerals. And part of the logic of Aloha attire is, of course, there's just too hot in Hawaii to wear a suit. But that doesn't explain why the shirts are so colorful
银行家在檀香山市中心穿的衣服。确实，檀香山市中心的银行家们都穿着阿罗哈衬衫。每个人都穿。他们甚至在葬礼上也穿。阿罗哈服饰的逻辑部分原因当然是，夏威夷太热了，穿西装受不了。但这并不能解释为什么这些衬衫如此色彩鲜艳、图案丰富且有趣。
and patterned and fun. They could have just as well worn plain white shirts, hypothetically. Truly, to understand the origins of the shirt, one must understand the origins of the state. Aloha kaahihah. Bleh. Got to pronounce it correctly. Aloha kaahihaka. Bleh. Got to pronounce it correctly.
假设一下，他们完全可以穿纯白衬衫。真的，要了解这种衬衫的起源，必须了解这个州的起源。Aloha kaahihah。呃。得发音正确。Aloha kaahihaka。呃。得发音正确。
Aloha kaha kaha kaha. That's good morning in Hawaiian. This is Zita Cup Choi, the historian of Yolani Palace. Yolani Palace is the last official residence of the monarchs who ruled Hawaii as a combined kingdom for 100 years and whose predecessors ruled here for over a thousand years prior to that. Ulaani Palace is the only actual bonafide palace on United States soil. Thornroom, ballroom, reception room, formal receptions here.
Aloha kaha kaha kaha。那是夏威夷语的“早上好”。这位是伊奥拉尼宫（Yolani Palace）的历史学家齐塔·库普·崔（Zita Cup Choi）。伊奥拉尼宫是统治夏威夷联合王国100年的君主们的最后一处官方住所，他们的前任在此之前已经统治了这里一千多年。伊奥拉尼宫是美国领土上唯一真正名副其实的宫殿。宝座室、宴会厅、接待室，这里曾举行过正式接待。
Receptions in the blue room would have included food beverages and entertainment. Ulaani Palace is truly elegant with sumptuous wooden staircases and crystal glassware, and what was then cutting-edge technology. They had electricity in 1887. Four years before the White House in Washington, D.C. The king also installed a telephone. Oh, yeah, by 1889, Honolulu probably had more phones per person than any other city of the same size anywhere else in the world.
蓝厅的接待活动包括食物、饮料和娱乐。伊奥拉尼宫确实优雅，有豪华的木制楼梯、水晶玻璃器皿，以及当时最尖端的技术。他们在1887年就有了电。比华盛顿特区的白宫早了四年。国王还安装了电话。哦，是的，到1889年，檀香山的人均电话拥有量可能比世界上任何其他同等规模的城市都要多。
This is all just to say, Hawaii as an independent constitutional monarchy transcended its tiny geography. The kingdom was technologically advanced and known diplomatically all over the world. Queen Lidio Kalani, our last monarch, is in the portrait on the wall over here. In this portrait, she is wearing the gown that was created to be worn at Queen Victoria's Golden Jubilee in London. Lillio Kalani became Queen of Hawaii in 1891. And she was a musician as well. She was a musician, she composed over 150 different songs, including Aloha Oy.
这一切只是为了说明，作为一个独立的君主立宪制国家，夏威夷超越了其狭小的地理位置。这个王国在技术上很先进，在外交上享誉全球。我们的最后一位君主莉莉乌欧卡拉尼女王（Queen Liliʻuokalani）的肖像就在这边的墙上。在这幅肖像中，她穿着为伦敦维多利亚女王金禧庆典而制作的礼服。莉莉乌欧卡拉尼于1891年成为夏威夷女王。她也是一位音乐家，她创作了150多首不同的歌曲，包括《Aloha ʻOe》。
It's a really famous song. Aloha Oy is actually a love song. Aloha Oy means goodbye to you. It was written in 1878. She saw a woman and a man saying goodbye to each other. And it was such a touching scene as she was coming home. She's humming and writing in her head. She had a wonderful ability to write songs.
这是一首非常有名的歌。《Aloha ʻOe》实际上是一首情歌。《Aloha ʻOe》的意思是“再见”。它写于1878年。她看到一对男女在告别。当她回家时，那是一个非常感人的场景。她一边哼唱一边在脑海中创作。她有极佳的写歌天赋。
So we're talking about Liliokolani because she's a major character in the story of how Hawaii became a territory and then part of the United States, which led to the rise of the Aloha shirt. And in many ways, this all starts with sugar. Sugar became a minor industry until the Civil War, when the sugar planters in the United States could no longer grow because they were fighting the war. So the sugar indices skyrocketed in influence and in income. Most of the sugar plantations were owned by Americans and Europeans. Many of the Hawaiians may not have had the money
所以我们谈论莉莉乌欧卡拉尼是因为她是夏威夷如何成为领土，然后成为美国一部分这一故事中的重要人物，这导致了阿罗哈衬衫的兴起。在很多方面，这一切都始于糖。在内战之前，糖只是一个小产业，当时美国的糖种植园因为战争而无法种植。因此，糖业的影响力和收入飙升。大多数糖料种植园由美国人和欧洲人拥有。许多夏威夷人可能没有钱
to be able to buy the property, some of the immigrants did, particularly those that have family that have money. The European and American sugar magnets who had been setting up plantations all over the Hawaiian islands worked their way into the legislature of Hawaii to give themselves better deals on shipping and tariffs. They imposed a constitution that dramatically reduced the power of the monarchy into more of a figurehead.
去购买这些房产，但一些移民有，特别是那些有钱的家庭。在夏威夷群岛各地建立种植园的欧洲和美国糖业大亨们设法进入了夏威夷立法机构，为自己在航运和关税方面争取更好的交易。他们强加了一部宪法，极大地削弱了君主制的权力，使其更多地成为一个象征性职位。
The constitution also allowed non-Hawaiian citizens to vote. And allowed non-citizen residents of American and European ancestry. Basically, it was those who could read or write English or some other European language to vote. So, it disenfranchised more native Hawaiians, left out the huge Chinese community. She's already in the Europeans, what why can't we? This allowed American and European business interest to meddle in Hawaiian government even more. And so, with what little power she had, Lili O'Kallani tried to get that imposed constitution repealed.
宪法还允许非夏威夷公民投票。并允许具有美国和欧洲血统的非公民居民投票。基本上，就是那些能读写英语或其他欧洲语言的人可以投票。因此，它剥夺了更多夏威夷原住民的选举权，并将庞大的华人社区排除在外。她已经是欧洲人了，为什么我们不能？这使得美国和欧洲的商业利益集团更加干预夏威夷政府。因此，莉莉乌欧卡拉尼利用她仅存的一点权力，试图废除那部强加的宪法。
Her attempts to put into effect a new constitution caused a group of 13 local residents of American and European ancestry to create the Committee of Public Safety to protect their own interests. That's a group that deposed Lili O'Kallani. The long and short of it is that well-connected businessmen used the U.S. military as backing for a coup.
她试图实施新宪法的举动导致一群13名具有美国和欧洲血统的当地居民成立了“公共安全委员会”来保护他们自己的利益。这就是那个废黜莉莉乌欧卡拉尼的组织。简而言之，关系密切的商人们利用美国军队作为政变的后盾。
In 1893, the monarchy was overthrown and a provisional government was established, and the queen was accused of treason. And then they arrested Lady O'Colani. They brought her here to this room. This is called the imprisonment room. This is where she was held under house arrest, very sparsely furnished, and initially no writing materials. For eight months, Liliokolani was prisoner in this front room of Ilani Palace, where the
1893年，君主制被推翻，临时政府成立，女王被指控叛国。然后他们逮捕了莉莉乌欧卡拉尼。他们把她带到了这个房间。这被称为“监禁室”。这就是她被软禁的地方，家具非常简陋，最初没有书写材料。八个月来，莉莉乌欧卡拉尼一直被囚禁在伊奥拉尼宫的前厅里，那里
sunlight streams in hot. And for lack of writing materials, Liliokolani and her one permitted companion, Sode. She made a quilt from brocaded silk fabrics and ribbons from her own wardrobe, and she stitched them with the names of her friends and supporters. Embroidered are the words imprisoned at Yolani Palace. And that says we began this quilt there, which means they completed it elsewhere. The quilt was probably completed after Liliokalani
阳光炽热地射入。由于缺乏书写材料，莉莉乌欧卡拉尼和她唯一被允许的同伴索德（Sode）一起，用她自己衣柜里的锦缎丝绸面料和丝带制作了一床被子，并缝上了她朋友和支持者的名字。上面绣着“囚禁于伊奥拉尼宫”的字样。那上面写着“我们在那里开始制作这床被子”，这意味着他们在别处完成了它。这床被子可能是在莉莉乌欧卡拉尼
moved to her private residence down the street, where she continued her life as a private citizen until she died in 1917. She was considered until her death as queen of Hawaii. And respected as such. And the queen's quilt would not be the last time a story of Hawaii would be told in cloth. From overthrow to statehood, Hawaii was in sort of limbo as a territory.
搬到街上的私人住所后完成的，她在那里继续作为一名普通公民生活，直到1917年去世。直到去世，她都被视为夏威夷女王，并受到相应的尊重。女王的被子不会是最后一个用布料讲述的夏威夷故事。从推翻君主制到成为州，夏威夷作为领土一直处于某种不确定的状态。
The sugar industry had changed everything, from the Constitution to the configuration of the government, to the actual makeup of the population of the Hawaiian islands. The Hawaiian islands from the late 1800s up to 1924 were the scene of many different immigrants coming in to work in the sugar industry. The sugar plantation owners, mostly white Americans and Europeans, recruited field workers from China, Korea, the Philippines, and Portugal. But the main group came from Japan. This is Decioto Brown, the historian at the Bishop Museum in Honolulu. And the federal government of the United States ended Asian immigration in 1924, but by that
糖业改变了一切，从宪法到政府的配置，再到夏威夷群岛人口的实际构成。从19世纪末到1924年，夏威夷群岛是许多不同移民前来糖业工作的场所。糖料种植园主，主要是白人美国人和欧洲人，从中国、韩国、菲律宾和葡萄牙招募田间工人。但主要群体来自日本。这位是檀香山毕晓普博物馆（Bishop Museum）的历史学家德西奥托·布朗（Decioto Brown）。美国联邦政府在1924年结束了亚洲移民，但到那时，
time, the population of Hawaii was about 40% ethnically Japanese. So on Hawaii, there was a huge market for Japanese products, including Japanese fabric. The Japanese fabric was a width which was made specifically for kimonos, which is the Japanese national costume. And there was one particular company in downtown Honolulu that was called Musesuya. Musesuya sold Japanese fabric and you could go in and choose the fabric you liked and they would make a shirt for you. So you could buy a western style collard shirt made out of kimono fabric.
夏威夷约40%的人口是日本裔。因此，在夏威夷，日本产品（包括日本面料）有巨大的市场。日本面料的宽度是专门为和服制作的，和服是日本的民族服装。檀香山市中心有一家特别的公司叫“武藏屋”（Musesuya）。武藏屋出售日本面料，你可以进去选择你喜欢的面料，他们会为你制作一件衬衫。所以你可以买到一件用和服面料制作的西式领衬衫。
It became a fun special thing to buy, especially for the youths. By about 1936 or 37, local manufacturers then began to have fabric custom made with tropical or Pacific or Hawaiian motifs in addition to the Japanese motifs which were already available. Kahala, the company you heard cutting the piles of shirts, was established in 1936, and it was one of the first to mass produce alohha shirts. Because these shirts sold like hotcakes as souvenirs, when Americans first started coming to Hawaii on mass, as soldiers and as tourists. And so it was always intended to be like souvenir shirts.
它成了一种有趣且特别的购买选择，尤其是对年轻人来说。到1936年或37年左右，当地制造商开始定制带有热带、太平洋或夏威夷图案的面料，以补充已经存在的日本图案。你刚才听到在切割衬衫堆的那家公司——卡哈拉，成立于1936年，是第一批大规模生产阿罗哈衬衫的公司之一。因为当美国人作为士兵和游客开始大规模来到夏威夷时，这些衬衫作为纪念品卖得非常火。所以它一直被定位为纪念品衬衫。
GIs, there is the desire to have something as a reminder, a token, a souvenir of the experience. And then when they went back home after World War II and all that, they brought that trend back with them. But Aloha shirts were still niche. People didn't wear them around in a real way. Even on the territory of Hawaii, it looked like the West had won.
大兵们，有一种想要留下某种纪念、信物或体验纪念品的需求。然后当他们在二战后回家时，他们把这种趋势带了回去。但阿罗哈衬衫仍然很小众。人们并没有真正地穿它们。即使在夏威夷领地，看起来也像是西方赢了。
Everyone was dressed like they lived in an American metropolis. Prior to 1962, it wouldn't be unusual to see everybody in downtown Honolulu wearing a suit and tie. You know, it'd be 90 degrees outside with 90% humidity and everyone's walking around a suit and tie. It's ridiculous. This is Josh Feldman, CEO of Tori Richard, which is a resort wear company and the parent
每个人都穿得好像住在某个美国大都市一样。1962年之前，在檀香山市中心看到每个人都穿着西装打着领带并不稀奇。你知道，外面是90度（华氏度）的高温，湿度90%，每个人都穿着西装打着领带走来走去。这太荒谬了。这位是乔什·费尔德曼（Josh Feldman），度假服饰公司Tori Richard的首席执行官，也是
company of Kahala, the Aloha wear manufacturer. So Josh's father, Mort Feldman, was the founder of the company. And even he, the founder of a resort-ware company, used to wear a suit and tie to work every day. My father in the 1950s and 60s, he's wearing like a total madman suit, you know, pocket square. I mean, it's a dapper-looking guy,
阿罗哈服饰制造商卡哈拉的母公司。乔什的父亲莫特·费尔德曼（Mort Feldman）是该公司的创始人。即使是他，一家度假服饰公司的创始人，也曾经每天穿着西装打着领带去上班。我父亲在50和60年代，他穿着那种完全疯狂的西装，你知道，还有口袋方巾。我的意思是，他是个看起来很时髦的人，
but it's kind of farcical, right, that in the middle of the Pacific, on a kind of tropical island, and you're wearing a suit and tie to work every day. Josh's father joined forces with some other Aloha attire manufacturers, and they formed a lobbying group called the Hawaiian Fashion Guild. And in 1962, they began a campaign
但这有点滑稽，对吧？在太平洋中部，在一个热带岛屿上，你每天却穿着西装打着领带去上班。乔什的父亲与其他一些阿罗哈服饰制造商联手，成立了一个名为“夏威夷时尚协会”（Hawaiian Fashion Guild）的游说团体。1962年，他们发起了一场
called Operation Liberation. It's all campaign called Operation Liberation. It's all started with Operation Liberation, which was to get men to wear Aloha Tire in the summer months. In Operation Liberation, the Hawaiian fashion guild gave each state representative and senator to Aloha shirts. And then, they took it a step further. They decided, let's lobby and get the state legislature just the state legislature on Fridays
名为“解放行动”（Operation Liberation）的运动。这一切都始于“解放行动”，旨在让男士在夏季月份穿上阿罗哈服饰。在“解放行动”中，夏威夷时尚协会给了每位州代表和参议员两件阿罗哈衬衫。然后，他们更进一步。他们决定，游说州立法机构，让州立法机构在周五
to wear products from Hawaii manufacturers. They got a resolution passed in 1967 formally creating a Loha Fridays. Formally creating a Loha Friday that required all the state legislatures to wear this product. That meant every Friday members of the state legislature wore a low-hashirts. And then that spreads to the business community as a way to support the manufacturers.
穿夏威夷制造商的产品。他们在1967年通过了一项决议，正式设立了“阿罗哈星期五”（Aloha Fridays）。正式设立了“阿罗哈星期五”，要求所有州立法机构成员穿这种产品。这意味着每个周五，州立法机构的成员都会穿阿罗哈衬衫。然后这扩展到商业界，作为支持制造商的一种方式。
And then people once they started doing that, they're like, hey, this is a heck of a lot more comfortable than wearing a suit. And that went on for a number of years and pretty much every day became a low-hash Friday. On any given day of the week in downtown Honolulu, you can see people in a low-hush shirts. Not in a Jimmy Buffett vacation kind of way, it's a workplace casual kind of way. And to this day, this especially ramps up on Fridays. And if you live in the mainland United States, this notion of a casual Friday might sound vaguely familiar to you.
然后人们一旦开始这样做，他们就会说，嘿，这比穿西装舒服多了。这种情况持续了几年，几乎每一天都变成了“阿罗哈星期五”。在檀香山市中心的任何一天，你都能看到穿着阿罗哈衬衫的人。不是那种吉米·巴菲特（Jimmy Buffett）式的度假风，而是一种职场休闲风。直到今天，这种情况在周五尤为明显。如果你住在美国大陆，这种“休闲星期五”的概念听起来可能对你来说有点耳熟。
Casual Friday has its origins with a low-hot Friday. And Casual Friday would go on to affect how we all dress at work. Not just in Hawaii, all over the United States. The Casual Friday campaign started and everyone credits dockers. Dockers is a company that makes khakis, and they are owned by Levi Strauss jeans. They fully acknowledge that the concept was created here. They do. We're here on the West Coast, a loha and the prince.
“休闲星期五”起源于“阿罗哈星期五”。而“休闲星期五”后来影响了我们所有人上班时的着装方式。不仅在夏威夷，在整个美国都是如此。“休闲星期五”运动开始时，每个人都归功于Dockers。Dockers是一家生产卡其裤的公司，隶属于李维斯（Levi Strauss）牛仔裤。他们完全承认这个概念是在这里创造的。他们确实承认。我们现在在西海岸，阿罗哈和印花。
Once a loha shirt hit the scene, Levi's started manufacturing them. We'd actually been doing a loha shirt since the 30s. I hear a Levi Strauss in company. This is Tracy Panic, historian at Levi Strauss in company. But you needed a companion piece, and we introduced in the early, in the 90s, we introduced the idea to human resources departments that you could let your workers come to work,
一旦阿罗哈衬衫出现，李维斯就开始生产它们。我们实际上从30年代就开始做阿罗哈衬衫了。我听到了李维斯公司的声音。这位是特蕾西·帕尼克（Tracy Panic），李维斯公司的历史学家。但你需要一件配套的单品，我们在90年代初向人力资源部门介绍了这个想法，即你可以让员工来上班，
dress one day a week in something a little bit more casual, dockers, for instance. And with dockers, Levi's really created the concept of business casual wear, which they then sold to businesses. We took the idea to human resources departments. In fact, we created a kit, how to put casual business wear to work. And we sent thousands around to HR departments, and in it, it included a guide to what was appropriate wear.
每周有一天穿得更休闲一点，比如穿Dockers。通过Dockers，李维斯真正创造了“商务休闲装”的概念，然后他们将其卖给了企业。我们将这个想法带到了人力资源部门。事实上，我们制作了一个工具包，关于如何将商务休闲装应用到工作中。我们向人力资源部门发送了数千份，其中包含了一份关于什么是合适着装的指南。
And in this guide that we're looking at, here's a man dressed in his docker slacks and a collared shirt and other clothing that he could wear. A Loha Friday came from Hawaii, but Casual Friday came from Levi Strauss and Company. We are credited Levi Strauss and Company for creating business casual Fridays, this business casual movement.
在我们正在看的这份指南中，这里有一个穿着Dockers休闲裤和领衬衫以及其他他可以穿的衣服的男人。“阿罗哈星期五”来自夏威夷，但“休闲星期五”来自李维斯公司。我们归功于李维斯公司创造了商务休闲星期五，这场商务休闲运动。
And now it's not just one day a week. A business casual for many workplace environments is okay all through the week. This might be one of the largest seismic shifts in recent fashion history. This turn to casual. A cotton and orlon dress with detachable collar and cuffs and plastron buttoned front. Goodbye silk ties and garters and stockings and knowing how, and a plasgron buttoned front. Goodbye, silk ties, and garters, and stockings, and knowing how to use an iron. Ship shapes the word.
现在不仅仅是每周一天了。对于许多工作环境来说，商务休闲装在整个一周都是可以接受的。这可能是近期时尚史上最大的地震式转变之一。这种向休闲的转变。一件带有可拆卸领子、袖口和胸前纽扣的棉质或奥纶（orlon）连衣裙。再见，丝绸领带、吊袜带、长筒袜，以及知道如何使用熨斗。船型形状这个词。
Hello, to CEOs in sweatshirts. And it's not that casual Friday invented casual wear. That is a much larger phenomenon that has its roots in the rise of leisure time and the rise of sportswear and the influx of college students stressing more practically to traverse campuses. What casual Friday gave us was a foot in the door to help casual wear spread into public life. Where does casual break in terms of when does it start to be worn to churches? Regional specific. This is Deirdre Clemente, historian of 20th century clothing and fashion,
你好，穿着运动衫的首席执行官们。并不是说“休闲星期五”发明了休闲装。那是一个更大的现象，其根源在于闲暇时间的增加、运动装的兴起，以及大学生为了穿梭校园而穿得更实用。休闲星期五给我们提供了一个切入点，帮助休闲装传播到公共生活中。休闲装在什么时候开始穿去教堂？这是区域性的。这位是迪尔德丽·克莱门特（Deirdre Clemente），20世纪服装和时尚历史学家，
an author of the book Dress Casual. And she says business casual was this tipping point, because the office was kind of the last vestige of everyday formal wear. The office was the last place to break, which I think because it's such a public front, the places where people had more interaction with clients, like maybe banks, say, or somebody who was a sales rep who had to go into it, those guys kept the most formal elements of clothes. And yes, many bankers and politicians still wear suits.
也是《休闲着装》（Dress Casual）一书的作者。她说商务休闲装是一个转折点，因为办公室是日常正式着装的最后堡垒。办公室是最后一个被攻破的地方，我认为因为它是如此公开的前沿，人们与客户有更多互动的地方，比如银行，或者必须进入办公室的销售代表，那些人保留了最正式的服装元素。是的，许多银行家和政客仍然穿西装。
But for a lot of industries now where workers sit in front of a computer, they don't need to change into heels or iron a jacket. I think casual dress speaks to Americans desire to be comfortable. It speaks to our desire to create in many ways a classless society. Or at least the appearance of a classless society. So I think the rise of casual dress in the United States speaks to America as a nation where everybody considers themselves middle class,
但对于现在许多在电脑前工作的行业来说，他们不需要换上高跟鞋或熨烫夹克。我认为休闲着装反映了美国人想要舒适的愿望。它反映了我们想要在许多方面创造一个无阶级社会的愿望。或者至少是无阶级社会的外观。所以我认为美国休闲着装的兴起反映了美国作为一个每个人都认为自己是中产阶级的国家，
no matter who you ask. 70% of Americans, poor or wealthy, call themselves middle class. Casual dress really speaks to everyone's who would have wanted to dress more towards the socioeconomic middle than the edges. It's almost uncool to dress up too much now. Dressing up would call too much attention to yourself, and in that way, the aloha shirt is a beautiful
无论你问谁。70%的美国人，无论贫富，都称自己为中产阶级。休闲着装确实反映了每个人都想向社会经济中间层而不是边缘层靠拢。现在穿得太正式几乎是不酷的。穿得太正式会引起太多的关注，从这个意义上说，阿罗哈衬衫是一个美丽的
aberration. When I think of aloha shirts, I think of my dad because my dad wears almost solely aloha shirts. He has probably a hundred aloha shirts because he wears one to work every single day, and he's like obsessed with buying different ones, where he'll get really into the pattern and be like, oh, I really like this textile or whatever. And a low-hushert is bright. And a low-hushert is colorful and bold. And it tells a story.
偏差。当我想到阿罗哈衬衫时，我会想到我爸爸，因为我爸爸几乎只穿阿罗哈衬衫。他可能有上百件阿罗哈衬衫，因为他每天上班都穿一件，而且他沉迷于购买不同的款式，他会非常深入地研究图案，然后说，哦，我真的很喜欢这种纺织品之类的。阿罗哈衬衫很明亮。阿罗哈衬衫色彩鲜艳且大胆。它讲述了一个故事。
Yes, about a fish or a bird or a plant, but also quietly about the whole history of a little chain of islands that left an Words from yesterday. There's a portrait painted on the things we love. Articles of interest is made by myself, Avery Truffleman, edited by Joe Rosenberg, music by Ray Royal, intro and outro themes by Sassami Ashworth, fact check by Graham Haysha, mixed by Kelly Coin, and Roman Mars is the big kahuna of this whole series.
是的，关于鱼、鸟或植物，但也悄悄地讲述了一个小岛链的完整历史，它留下了昨天的文字。我们所爱的事物上画着一幅肖像。《感兴趣的物品》由我本人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）制作，乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）编辑，雷·罗亚尔（Ray Royal）配乐，萨萨米·阿什沃思（Sassami Ashworth）创作片头和片尾主题曲，格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）事实核查，凯利·科恩（Kelly Coin）混音，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）是整个系列的大老板。
Thank you to Dale Hope, Linda Arthur Bradley, Vic Wong and the Alcatraz Islanders, Quora Currier, and Michelle Leigh at Jam's World, as well as Katie Mingle, Vivian Lee, Delaney Hall, Kirk Kohlstead, Shreep Youssef, Seanry Al, Emmett Fitzgerald, and the whole 99PI team. Mahalo. There's a portrait of painting the things we love. The rise of casual wear in many ways has been the rise of synthetics. You start to see America's really accepting synthetic fibers, acrylic fibers going into
感谢戴尔·霍普（Dale Hope）、琳达·亚瑟·布拉德利（Linda Arthur Bradley）、维克·王（Vic Wong）和阿尔卡特拉斯岛民（Alcatraz Islanders）、科拉·库里尔（Quora Currier）和Jam's World的米歇尔·李（Michelle Leigh），以及凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、柯克·科尔斯特德（Kirk Kohlstead）、什里普·优素福（Shreep Youssef）、肖恩里·阿尔（Seanry Al）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）和整个99PI团队。Mahalo（谢谢）。我们所爱的事物上画着一幅肖像。休闲装的兴起在许多方面是合成纤维的兴起。你开始看到美国人真正接受合成纤维，丙烯酸纤维进入
sweaters, dachron, all that kind of stuff, you know, all the name brand, DuPont sponsored, fibers going into sweaters, menswear, huge menswear, with synthetic fibers breaking, huge. For good reasons, we are sick of trying to fit into our clothes, and we want our clothes to fit us. We want stretch. We want a little give. We want flexibility, which comes at a price. Your next article of interest is denim. Radio Topeo. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
毛衣、涤纶，所有这些东西，你知道，所有杜邦赞助的名牌纤维进入毛衣、男装，巨大的男装，合成纤维的突破，巨大的。有充分的理由，我们厌倦了试图适应我们的衣服，我们想要我们的衣服适应我们。我们想要弹性。我们想要一点余地。我们想要灵活性，这是有代价的。你的下一件感兴趣的物品是牛仔布。Radio Topeo。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。